Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192. David P I don't know what I must
have said to cause this, but someone called
in and asked about how I celebrate Christmas.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. I know that your
Argentinean heritage is very important to you,
and you're teaching your daughter Spanish
and all about that. Right? So I was curious,
what does your holiday tradition look like?
Is it an Argentinean Christmas or Hanukkah
or a combination of all those things or more
of a traditional looking American Christmas?
I'm just curious about what it looks like or
maybe there's a specific tradition you embrace.
Speaker 1: Yes, I embrace the tradition of
Asian food on Christmas. I am I'm Jewish,
so there is no Christmas celebration in my
house. My daughter will not be celebrating
Christmas because we aren't Christian and we
don't celebrate Christmas. So it has nothing to
do with being Argentinean or an American citizen
or any of those different things. The tradition on
Christmas is a Jewish tradition where I believe
even though the default is often Chinese food,
I believe Indian food is absolutely fine on
Christmas. I've never gone for it like Thai
or Cambodian or Vietnamese food on Christmas, but
I think it would be fine. It's really whatever's
open, but typically it is either Chinese food
or this particular Christmas it was Indian
food. So that is going to be the tradition. And
yeah, I don't know what I might have said that
would have made someone think I. I celebrate
Christmas, but I'm glad to answer questions
about Indian or Chinese food at any time. We
have a great bonus show for you today. The sax,
the sax, the sex trafficking saxophone.
The sex trafficking investigation into
Republican Matt Gaetz is being dropped.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money.
Speaker 1: Yep.
Speaker 4: Everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Matt Gaetz will not be charged. We
will talk about it. New childhood obesity guidance
is raising concerns over the risk of eating
disorders. And the Democrat who nearly unseated
Lauren Boebert, Adam Fresh, has announced he is
running against her again in 2024. It came down
to just such a small margin. What can we do to
really be sure we remove Boebert in 24? Is it wise
for Adam fresh to announce his candidacy so early
or not? We are going to talk about all of that
on today's bonus show. I would really love for
you to become a member, not just because you'll
get access to the bonus show, but because we do
depend on members to fund the program. Our primary
funding source, the plurality of our dollars
come from the membership program you can sign
up at join Packman Qcom. You can use the coupon
code. 24 starts now. And boy, has it started. 24
starts now. That's two, four starts now. All one
word to get a discount off of a membership, you'll
get access to the bonus, show the commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show, invitations to
the members only town halls and access to the
members only soundboard when I play the clips.
Nokia collaboration, right? Virat Kohli.
Speaker 4: Yes, that is a frickin
predator right there.
Speaker 1: That soundboard
we make available to our members. So all great
benefits to take advantage of sign up at join
Pacman dot com. And remember if you have a parent,
a friend whatever who could use some American
political commentary in Spanish. The Spanish
YouTube channel has launched it is at David Pakman
dot com slash Spanish. We're working on our first
thousand subscribers. There. It's an exciting
new project. Make sure whoever it is that would
prefer to consume this sort of content in Spanish
rather than English is aware of it. David Pakman.
Scots. Spanish. I will see you on the bonus site.